en sismologie on appelle ça une réplique
cette secousse sismique qui suit un
séisme majeur et qui peut être aussi
dévastatrice la loi immigration votée
hier soir a provoqué ce matin la
démission du ministre de la Santé
Aurélien Rousseau et beaucoup d'élus
macroniste issu de la gauche se sent mal
à l'aise jusqu'où ira cette front de la
majorité présidentielle est-elle
durablement fracturé avant d'en débattre
Jérôme Rabier nous raconte le jour
d'après lendemain de vote compliqué pour
l'exécutif et sa majorité plus fracturé
que jamais des ténors à l'Assemblée ont
voté contre le texte immigration ù se
sont abstenus comme Sacha alier le
président de la commission des lois ou
encore le chef de fil des députés modem
Jean-Paul Matth mais pas question pour
Elisabeth borne de laisser la déprime
s'installer quit à nier toute crise dans
son camp vous savez j'ai passé je vous
dis des heures avec les députés je peux
vous assurer qu' y a pas de crise dans
la majorité on souhaite avancer
continuer à avancer dans le cap fixé par
le président de la République dans la
matinée la démission du ministre de la
Santé Aurélien Rousseau a pourtant été
confirmé il était farouchement opposé à
plusieurs volets du texte chargé du
compterendu du Conseil des ministres
Olivier verrand a dû batailler pour
continuer à défendre l'unité du
gouvernement il y a pas de mouvement de
fronde ministériel je je je le conteste
que des ministres des membres des
gouvernements d'un gouvernement qui sont
qui font de la politique et des
questions des
qu'il puissent discuter ou entre eux ou
relayer le interrogations la première
ministre ça me paraît plutôt être de
bonne politique mais dans les autres
camp les opposants persistent le RN
revendique une victoire idéologique l'R
une victoire totale et la gauche dénonce
un texte qui ne serait pas passé si le
RN avait voté contre interpellé aux
questions d'actualité au Sénat le
ministre de l'intérieur reste droit dans
seses nous avons faire voter un texte
sans compter les voies du rassemblement
national par nous avons le nous avions
le sens de l'honneur alors que vous vous
n'avez que le sens de la petite
politique le gouvernement a tout de même
concéder que certaines dispositions du
texte le gêner mais que le Conseil
constitutionnel pourrait être un allié
si jamais quelques dispositions polmique
était censuré c'est Emmanuel Macron en
personne qui a chargé les sages de
l'examiner le chef de l'État qui doit
s'exprimer dans quelques minutes s'en
expliquera devant les Français mais il
est aussi sans doute très attendu par sa
propre majorité
Emmanuel Macron peut-il ressouder sa
majorité on en débat avec Sophie
Coignard bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes journaliste éditorialiste politique
au point et vous publiez la tyrannie de
la médiocrité pourquoi il faut sauver le
mérite aux éditions de
l'Observatoire Franck Morel bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi avocat associé
chez flichi Granger ancien conseiller
social d'Édouard Philippe amatignon et
de plusieurs ministres et vous êtes
expert à l'Institut Montaigne Catherine
tricot bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes la
directrice de la revue regard et Mathieu
croissandau éitoraliste politique est
resté à mes côtés Sophie cigner
peut-être une question assez générale
pour démarrer que retiendra-t-on de
cette loi immigration l'histoire d'un
piège politique peut-être
de l'ffet Domino absolument hallucinant
enfin avec une accélération de la
manière dont les dominos tombent au de
Merant parce que finalement on peut
enfin une façon de dater les choses
c'est c'est de les dat du moment où
Emmanuel Macron après avoir changé 53
fois d'avis décide de faire une loi en
même temps c'est-à-dire avec à la fois
le répressif et à la fois le euh bah le
régularisateur enfin les régularisation
bon à partir de ce moment-là alors c'est
facile de faire Sam malgne après je
reconnais mais on peut
dérouler tout ce qui va se passer d'une
manière ou d'une autre c'estàd c'est
quelque chose qui ne satisfait personne
et puis évidemment les les les enfin les
choses s'accélèent terriblement le le la
borne qu'on peut mettre s mauvais Jeet
de mot pardon c'est euh lundi 11 euh
décembre la motion de rejet à partir de
ce moment-là effectivement
euh la
journée qui aurait dû être d'ailleurs
celle d'avan-hier et qui a été celle
d'hier faute de CMP conclusive allait
forcément être une journée entre
guillemets dramatique pour la majorité
et l'exécutif puisque soit c'était
comment dirais-je euh un recul en race
campagne avec un retrait du texte soit
c'était on l'a bien vu à partir de ce
weekend céder à ce qui est difficile de
ne pas appeler les caprices de LR qui a
trouvé là un moyen d'exister comme il
n'en avait pas eu depuis si longtemps on
y reviendra au rôle de LR évidemment
est-ce que Franck Morel c'est une crise
politique majeure pour ellisabeth borne
et pour Emmanuel Macron non je ne
diraisempyz pas ces mots là j'irais pas
jusque là effectivement parce que en la
matière on peut constater effectivement
la situation est pas évidente mais on
peut aussi comparer la situation à ce
qu'elle aurait été si par exemple le
texte n'était pas allé jusqu'au bout que
n'aurait-on dit sur l'incapacité du
gouvernement à mener une réforme et une
réforme attendue par nos concitoyens il
y avait encore des études d'opinion qui
montrai qu'il y avait une très très
forte attente en cette direction et on
peut dire au bout du bout que certes la
majorité en sort un peu fracturée
puisquil a un quart à peu près hein des
des parlementaires qui soit se sont
abstenus des parlementaires de la
majorité soit se sont abstenus soit on
voter contre donc c'est effectivement un
sujet de préoccupation mais on peut
aussi constater que le Parlement a joué
son rôle la navette parlementaire a joué
son rôle entre l'Assemblée et le Sénat
il y a eu un débat le texte tel qu'il
ressort n'est pas identique à ce qu'il
était dans à l'entrée au Parlement donc
ça veut dire qu'il y a eu un certain
nombre d'amendements qui ont été adoptés
et des échanges et donc ce que ce qui
était reproché au moment de la réforme
des retraites à travers l'usage du 493
là on est rigoureusement dans la D
dynamique inverse puisque effectivement
il y a eu un temps d'examen au Parlement
assez long alors je pense qu'il faudra
attendre un peu d'avoir un certains
recul pour savoir comment ça va se
manifester dans les prochains textes
cette cette coupure cette fracture
effectivement au sein de la majorité si
elle va trouver de nouvelles occasions
ou pas de prospérer je pense que
justement tout le challenge qui est
maintenant devant devant le président de
la République et devant la première
ministre qui qui s'en est pas mal sorti
la première ministre parce que dans la
dernière ligne droite elle a vraiment
pas ménagé sa peine et elle a réussi à
obtenir ce texte est-ce que dans les
prochains chantiers il y aura justement
une occasion de
remett et de redonner une dynamique
c'est toute la question mais à quel prix
Catherine tricot notamment sur le le
contenu sur le fond du texte un
renversement complet de ce qui était la
promesse d'Emmanuel Macron on se
souvient qu'en 2016 quand Angela Merkel
2015 2016 quand Angela Merkel ouvre les
portes au syriens millions de Syriens
qui fuit le régime de Bachar al-Assad et
la et la guerre en
Syrie manuel Vals s'oppose à Angela
Merkel et Emmanuel Macron la soutient
c'estàdire qu'Emmanuel Macron apparaît
et se positionne comme étant à la fois
évidemment un social libéral sur le plan
économique mais quand même plutôt un
libéral quelqu'un d'ouvert sur le monde
de d'accueillant au monde un peu c'est
il est l'alternative à Manuel Vals oui
mais depuis l'Allemagne on est revenue
de cette politique des mesures
restrictives qui sont pris ai là je
parle je parle de la position uel Macron
et comment il a constitué en marche sur
quelle base idéologique il a réussi à
raller tout un tas de ministres de
députés et tout son premier cercle je
dirais le premier cercle d'en marche
était quand même des gens qui étaient y
compris d'ailleurs du côté de la droite
par exemple autour de Alain Jupé ou du
MoDem c'était quand même ceux qui
étaient on va dire les humanistes de
gauche et de droite et puis là et ben
c'est un drôle de renversement de
situation c'est qu'on là idéologiquement
on est on a totalement retourné euh euh
la la le l'axe le la position politique
c'est les clés ont été données à
Darmanin pour ses calculs à la
politicien d'une part pour probablement
ses calculs politiques c'est à Darmanin
qui on se souvient a été le porte-parole
de Nicolas Sarkozi certainement pense
réitérer le coup de Sarkozi qui pense
que on va battre le Front national en en
allant sur son terrain en allant sur son
terrain le seul c'est le seul problème
alorsou je peux terminer voilà je
termine juste en un mot il il pense
qu'il va battre le Front national en se
mettant sur son terrain le problème
c'est que en 2007 Nicolas Sarkozi réussi
ça face à Jean-Marie Le Pen qui est en
bout de course et affaibli là on a un
extrême droite qui est extrêmement forte
entre 37 et 40 % qui est en dynamique et
et là c'est on met la main et c'est tout
ça qui est en train de partir et pour
l'instant d'ailleurs 37 40 % c'est dans
les der c'est la somme de des si on
parle des européenes la somme des intion
pour Jordan Bardella et pour ce que je
dis c'est que l'extrême droite est en
dynamique et en force et qu'on n pas du
tout 2007 et que leur donner leur donner
du grain à moudre c'est se faire manger
par l'extrême votre avis là-dessus sur
le finalement la peut-être une stratégie
obsolète qui aurait été appliquée par
Gérald Armin qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez sophieard euh bon moi d'abord je
suis je suis quand même assez perplexe
sur le fait effectivement que que on est
pris dans un engrenage qui va enfin j'ai
trouvé les les prop
dans la séance de nuit enfin de soirée
hier j'ai trouvé les propos de la gauche
extrêmement agréable pour Marine Le Pen
d'ailleurs qui ne cachait pas son
plaisir c'estd B c'està-dire que ils on
remettaient des couches sur ah la
préférence nationale maintenant ça y est
c'est fait c'est mort et cetera la
République est en danger enfin ils ils
ont faisait ils faisait de Marine Le Pen
l'immense triomphatrice de ce de cette
séquence alors qu'elle n'en soit pas la
grande perdante j'en suis d'accord mais
est-ce que c'est à la gauche franchement
de de de de de porter le bouclier du
chef pour Marine Le Pen ça c'est c'est
un vrai sujet le deuxème c'est un sujet
de fond c'est-à-dire est-ce
qu'effectivement on est dans une on est
sur la fameuse pente savonneuse
c'est-à-dire est-ce que la loi telle
qu'elle est et et enfin moi je trouve
qu'il y a des choses problématiques
notamment le fait que une première
ministre dise tout de suite après le
vote du texte et le ministre de
l'Intérieur aussi oh oui il y a sûrement
des trucs
inconstitutionneliend la constition
enfin je trouve quand même que c'est une
étrange manière de gouverner mais voilà
donc je il y a beaucoupê d'accord avec
vous y a beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
dire je veux pas dire par là que je
trouve ce texte vraiment génial mais
simplement je trouve que la
dramatisation qu' en est faite par la
gauche est une manière de servir Marine
Le Pen euh d'une part et est-ce qu'on
est sur ce sur cette P sa et d'autre bah
on on a eu un débat assez comparable ici
sur ce plateau il y a quelques temps et
et qui était vraiment passionnant je
trouvais sur qu quelle est la meilleure
manière de s'opposer à l'extrême droite
est-ce que c'est de comme l'avait fait
ellizabeth borne vous souvenez s'était
fait taper sur les doigts de rappeler
que au départ il y a un ramassie de
pééniste et de collabo en gros qui qui
crée qui fonde ce parti oou est-ce que
c'est comme l'avait dit Emmanuel Macron
en ayant du résultat alors effectivement
la première méthode ne marche pas mais
j'ai pas vraiment vu que la deuxième
marche aussi tout ça tout ça pour dire
que bien malin moi je n'ai pas la
réponse à la meilleure manière de
combattre le Front National et ce que je
crois aussi c'est que Sarkozi d'armanin
c'était j'arrête après mais c'était en
c'était en début c'était en campagne
c'est très difficile de faire la même
chose quand vous êtes plutôt en fin de
séquence Mathieu voulaz intervenir mais
rapide parce qu'il y a encore plein de
chose à dire non non mais je pense que
la pente savonneuse elle est liée aussi
à quelque chose c'est que faut jamais
oublier le rôle qu'on joué les
républicains les républicains sur les
questions d'immigration ont collé au
train du rassem nationale il y a une
interview dans le JDD qui date du 23 mai
et où on se dit tous en la lisant c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable c'est le
programme de Marine Le Pen noir sur
blanc or les républicains c'est l'allié
qu'a choisi Gérald daranin parce
pourquoi pourquoi les républicains parce
que c'est le seul 60 députés et c'est
les seul avec qui pouvait faire voter
son truc et en commençant au Sénat il
leur donne la main et donc le texte est
mécaniquement un texte calqué sur le
programme de Marine Le Pen et c'est ça
qui pose problème aujourd'hui parce que
les mesures qu'il y a moi je suis pas
d'accord avec vous elles sont
complètement contradctoir avec le
macronisme il y en a une qui apparaît
aujourd'hui que tout le monde redécouvre
sur la fameuse question des étudiants
étrangers on a un Emmanuel Macron qui
prône l'attractivité de la France qui
prône les filières d'excellence qui
prône le rayonnement de l'université
française et qui est en train d'imposer
une caution et des quotas à des
étudiants étrangers vous voyez tous les
présidents d'université tous les patrons
de grandes écoles qui sont en train de
tirer une tronche pas possible ce truc
c'est un petit exemple parce qu'il y en
a 1500 dans la loi allez je ressors du
du du fond pour parler des
conséquences de de de ce séisme
politique les répliques le risque de
fracture durable de la majorité
présidentielle bon elle compte déjà
cette majorité un ministre dé
missionnaires Aurélien Rousseau il a
laissé son siège vide lors du conseil
des ministres ce matin ministre de la
Santé écoutter le le porte-parole du
gouvernement constater les
dégâts d'abord je vous confirme la
démission du ministre chargé de la santé
et de la prévention Aurélien Rousseau
qui a présenté sa démission à la
première ministre et au président de la
République et qui était absent ce matin
en Conseil des ministres ministre
Aurélien Rousseau sera remplacé par
Agnès firmain le budeau actuellement
ministre délégué aux professions de
santé qui assurera
l'intérime Franck Morel il y a bon un
seul mini démissionnaire c'est presque
un moindre mal puisquon en avait cité
deux autres mais il y a surtout ces
députés modem Renaissance qui se sont
par dizaines abstenu qui ont voté contre
la loi quo c'est vous avez commencé à
l'évoquer tout à l'heure mais est-ce que
c'est le début d'une fronde c'est trop
tôt pour le dire effectivement on est on
est dans une une thématique particulière
très clivante à la fin d'une séquence
qui n'a pas été un long fleuve
tranquille c'est le loin queon puisse
dire et donc je pense que pour répondre
à votre question il faut voir quels vont
être les thèmes qui vont être mis sur la
table pour remettre du lion justement
dans la majorité alors on a plusieurs
choses falloir réformer à gauche alors
il y a par exemple l'inscription de la
liberté de de l'interruption en matière
d'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans la Constitution qui est sur la
table il y a la question de la fin de
Vim euh qui va peut-être également venir
devant le Parlement donc quels sont les
sujets qui vont effectivement permettre
de remettre du Lian après Aurélien
Rousseau et il a pris une décision et il
fait il fait vivre la dage bien connue
de de Jean-Pierre chevenenem vous savez
un ministre alors je vais pas utiliser
le terme exact voilà ça se tait on va
dire gentiment ou ça démissionne voilà
euh et donc il a choisi voilà il a
choisi de démissionner parce qu'il
n'était pas en accord effectivement avec
avec ce qu'il pensait profondément voilà
c'est c'est pas la première fois dans la
5e République il y eu d'utres d'autes
d'autres ministres qui ont démissionné
donc je pense qu'il faut après je veux
rebondir sur ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure sur les sur les étudiants
étrangers ce qui a commencer à dire et
il est possible qu'il va le qu'il va
continuer à le dire le président de la
République c'est qu'on est dans une
logique de compromis donc dans une
logique de compromis ça veut dire que
dans un texte global vous avez des
choses qui sont les choses qui étaient
proposées par le gouvernement ou qui
étaient soutenu par le gouvernement avec
beaucoup de conviction et puis les
choses qui sont dans accepté dans le
cadre de ce compromis c'estd peut-être à
tort ce que ce qu'on retient et on
revient à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure peut-être aussi sur le rôle de
la gauche c'est c'est priorité nationale
ou préférence nationale finalement c'est
un alors c'est sans doute caricatural
mais ce qu'on est en train de retenir de
cette loi ce sont ces deux mots vous
voyez ce que je veux dire oui c'est
alors c'est on est beaucoup dans la
posture politique parce qu'effectivement
quand vous regardez un certain nombre de
dispositions c'est l'élargissement pour
beaucoup de dispositions qui existe déjà
en terme de durée c'est-à-dire il y a
déjà des différences je vais pas rentrer
dans le détail technique mais il a déjà
des diff diff et donc dans un certain
nombre de cas c'est l'élargissement des
différences et puis encore une fois vous
je sais plus lequel d'entre nous le
disait tout à l'heure mais il faut aussi
regarder chez nos voisins et chez nos
voisins qui ont pu évoluer sur le sujet
y compris avec des majorités qui sont
des majorités parfois de gauche on pense
à l'Allemagne vous avez cité l'Allemagne
tout à l'heure on pourrait citer on le
cite sans arrêt le Danemark le directeur
de de l'Office central des des migration
a déclaré il y a pas longtemps je crois
que le la réglementation au Danemark
était beaucoup plus restrictive que ce
qu'elle est chez nous y compris après ce
texte Mathieu le le président de la
République prend la parole ce soir à la
télévision il il est quoi il est pressé
de passer à autre chose ah oui il avait
dit assez proche au lendemain du vote à
l'assemblée enfin de la motion de rejet
je ne ferai pas flotter ce sujet entre
Noël et le jour de l'an en gros le
premier objectif c'était de clore la
séquence comme disent les communicants
au plus vite et qu'elle soit positive ou
non c'estd qu'il y a un texte ou pas de
texte alors de ce point de vue est servi
le président peut se targer d'avoir
obtenu d' d'avoir obtenu un texte fus
dans des conditions absolument
calamiteuses et ce matin Olivier Verant
on l'a laissé entendre hein la loi sur
l'immigration est derrière nous ça c'est
le premier objectif second objectif
faire retomber la pression et donc c'est
ce qu'il va faire ce soir et de ce point
de vue le choix de l'émission C'est à
vous et quand même pas à noodin parce
que s'il avait parler bien sûr dans une
allocution depuis l'Élysée ou dans un
journal de 20H ça aurait été très
solennel ça aurait été reconnaître qu'il
y a cette fameuse crise politique que le
pouvoir refuse de voir alors que là
c'est une émission d'actualité mais
aussi de divertissement c'est plus cool
ça revient une forme de banalisation
trème objectif enfin passer à autre
chose alors avant même cette crise il
avait confié au journal de monde le
président imaginez un rendez-vous avec
la nation pour le mois de janvier bon
qui reste pour l'instant très fumeux ou
très gazux choisiss l'objectif que vous
voulez pour le mois de janvier afin de
sortir de la bangeche des 493 budgétaire
et de relancer la donne dans son quinena
en gros il redoute une chose c'est soit
d'être chirakisé donc le fameux
président la formule de Nicolas SAR soit
d'être hollandisé le fameux président
empêché de continuer son quinquena et
donc il veut dire je vais réformer
jusqu'au bout bon ça ce sont les
intentions bah ouais parce que dans les
fait ça risque évidemment d'être une
autre paire de manch d'abord parce que
le feuilleton de la loi immigration va
laisser des traces sur les chiquers
politiques d'abord on l'a dit ça
redonnait des couleurs à la droite qui
du coup ne va plus se sentir et va faire
monter la pression et les encher dans
tous les textes qui vont venir et puis
ça a redonné à un moment on est quand
même à 6 mois du scrutin européen
ça met le RN en position d'ultra force
quoi ensuite ça va laisser les traces
dans sa propre majorité on a d dit mot
voilà a-t-on été élu pour ça c'est la
phrase qui revient le plus en ce moment
chez de nombreux députés renaissances et
même chez des ministres la macronie
balance entre colère et désillusion et
voir hier près de 60 parlementaires
prendre leur autonomie pour la première
fois les fameux Playmobil vous savez là
en en votant contre ce texte ou en
s'abstenant ça a créé un précédent et du
coup va falloir savoir si c'était des
des frondeurs d'un soir
Hir etis dernier enje ENF et moindr
Emmanuel Macron a cassé sa boussole dans
cette affaire c'est le fameux en même
temps qui avait permis quand même de
faire adopter une cinquantaine de textes
depuis un an et demi un coup à gauche un
coup à droite et désormais un coup à
l'extrême droite ça devient très
compliqué comment rebondir bah il y a
pas beaucoup d'atouin la dissolution
c'est non le remanimement oui mais ça
sera d'une utilité si je ve dire si
c'est pas le fruit d'un accord politique
qui élargira sa majorité au Parlement
quand on référendum c'est une arme qui
paraît quand même sacrément risquée en
ce moment et évidemment Catherine tricot
la la ce qu'on entend aussi beaucoup
chez pas mal de députés Renaissance
c'est ok la loi immigration est derrière
nous mais la crise elle est devant c'est
ça c'est une formule qu'on entend qu'on
entend pas mal est-ce que effectivement
il va devoir quoi compter ses soutiens
texte après texte c'est c'est ce à quoi
on peut s'attendre pour les les
prochaines semaines pour l'instant c'est
ce qui s'est passé et ça va continuer
comme ça mais c'està dire qu'il n'y aura
pas de texte majeurs c'estd que tous les
textes ma vous pensez que ça va être une
une ambition moindre bah voilà ça va
être à bas bruit moi ce que je voulais
revenir un tout petit peu sur ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure est-ce que
la gauche doit porter en triomphe Marine
Le Pen sur un bouclier comme ça pour
dire que c'est son triomphe en fait ce
que je crois c'est que c'est pas du tout
ça ce que fait la gauche ce que fait la
gauche c'est qu'elle elle sonne de toxin
elle dit et c'est peut-être aussi une
leçon européenneelle le fait elle le
fait pas très bien si ben c'est possible
il faudrait de donner du conseil mais en
tout cas l'objectif de la gauche de dire
là franchement faut se ressaisir quoi
parce que si on continueoui je suis
assez d'accord avec Sophie card la
gauche en le faisant reprend à son
compte la communication duurn de dire ah
bah ce texte c'est la préférence
nationale mais c'est la vérité mais
c'est la vérité et le problème de la
gauche c'est de dire on ne peut pas
continuer d'alimenter et de valider et
d'installer de considérer que Chenu est
le meilleur des VI président de
l'Assemblée nationale et cetera que
comment il s'appelle Jordan Bardella
était un formidable interlocuteur pour à
ce momentlà fallait pas fallait pas
déposer de motion de rejet parce quebut
début est ce que d'abord c'est on
pourrait revenir sur cette sorte de
motion de rejet ce que je ce que oui
mais c'est un autre point mais celui que
je sur lequel je voulais insister
c'était que aujourd'hui ce que veut la
gauche et dire là il faut vraiment se
ressaisir et ce qui se passe dans le
reste de l'Europe est aussi une alerte
c'estàd que partout on voit monter
l'extrême droite et qu'on peut pas
continuer de penser qu'on va contourner
le problème tergiverser faire des petits
arrangements soit on la combat vraiment
sur ses idées sur ses propositions et on
peut la battre en votant avec elle non
là c'est pas en votant avec elle c'est
c'est la d'abord la motion de Roger a
été déposée par la gauche parce que la
gauche était contre ce texte ça c'est le
premier point le deè point non mais la
gauche a pas à refuser les voix du Front
national je veux dire la Gauche propose
une motion de reoget vote qui veut ça
c'est le premier point deuxième point il
faut pas raconter
d'histoireè
qu on voit le texte
auourd'hi possible oui j'entends bien
mais de toute façon il y aurait eu une
CMP on sait très bien que le texte de la
sortant sortant sortie du Sénat et celui
qui aurait été voté à
l'assembléur une c'est normal que la
gauche c'était normal que la gauche
s'ose à ce envie de prendre la parole
sur ce thème de la gauche parce que
effectivement il est important il est
passionnant on va
écouter l'une de ses représentantes
c'est la sénatrice socialiste
Marie-Pierre de la gontere elle
interpellait la première ministre cet
après-midi lors des questions
gouvernement vous avez jeté la majorité
présidentielle et le pays dans les bras
du Front National au soir de son
élection face à Marine Le Pen grâce aux
voix de la gauche Emmanuel Macron
promettait d'être un barrage face au
Front National et ses idées il ajoutait
j'ai conscience que ce vote m'oblige
aujourd'hui l'extrême droite n'a plus
besoin d'être élu vous appliquez son
programme et faites votre la PR érence
nationale vous affirmez pourtant que ce
projet de loi est conforme à vos valeurs
madame la Première ministre supprimer
laame est-ce conforme à vos valeurs
privz des étrangers en situation
régulière de prestation sociale est-ce
conforme à vos valeurs ferme la porte de
nos universités aux étudiants étrangers
est-ce conforme à vos valeurs écarter
des étrangers des dispositifs
d'hébergement d'urgence est-ce conformme
à vos valeurs soutenir un texte dont
plus de 20 mesures sont
inconstitutionnelles est-ce conforme à
vos ur vous vantez de ne pas respecter
les décisions de la CEDH est-ce cela vos
valeurs Franck Morel vous vouliez
intervenir évidemment en entendant
Catherine tricot voilà défendre la str
peut-être la stratégie finalement de de
la gauche alors je c'est un peu
simplificateur mais remontons à la
motion de rejet est-ce que cette motion
de rejet ne se retourne pas contre elle
si on si on voit le contenu de la loi
tel queelle a été complètement parce que
si on refait effectivement le film qu'on
rbobine et qu'on fait le film si la
motion de n'avait pas été voté il y
aurait effectivement probablement eu une
CMP mais le rapport de force au sein de
la CMP n'aurait pas du tout été le même
parce que on aurait eu un texte qui
aurait été issu d'un débat à l'Assemblée
qui aurait été très différent
potentiellement peut-être pas très
différent mais différent en tout cas du
texte issu du Sénat et la discussion
aurait été distinct de ce qu'elle a été
donc c'est quand même un point important
après quand j'entends effectivement la
sénatrice de la Gonterie s'exprimer je
trouve que
c'est ce que disait Sophie quagier tout
à l'heure on a une une forme de de
posture
politique grossi très très fortement
quand même de parler de préférence
nationale par rapport à un texte sur
lequel effectivement on peut dire un
certain nombre de choses sur les
étudiants par exemple mais qui
globalement est un compromis le plus
souvent avec
LR in lequel LR avait pompé
les avait mis en avant un certain nombre
de choses mais qui quand on regarde les
enquêtes d'opinion sont des choses sur
lesquelles il y a une très très for
forte résonance dans l'opinion il y a un
certain nombre de mesures et c'est
quelque chose quand quand on indique que
le Président de la République doit
entendre l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
bah c'est aussi des choses qu'il doit il
doit entendre est-ce que c'est efficace
on le verra ça j'en sais rien mais en
tout cas sur un certain nombre de
mesures ça renvoie à cette résonance
Emmanuel Macron première déclaration là
ce soir c'est le bouclier qui nous
manquait c'est peut-être la phrase que
qu'on qu'on qu'on retiendra il dit nous
continuont d'accueillir on doit se
battre contre les arrivées clandestines
et mieux intégrer les les travailleurs
cette loi le fruit d' d'un compromis
voilà l'essentiel de de de ce qu'il a
déclaré sur ce texte immigration vous
posiez la question de savoir enfin on se
demande si la séquence est terminée
c'est évidemment ce que souhaite le
président en faisant son son émission ce
soir il me semble qu'il y a un sujet
qu'il faut qu'on regarde qu'on observe
c'est aussi ce que vont faire les
collectivités territoriales de gauche on
a vu aujourdh deux Conseils
départementaux beaucoup plus on est à 32
on est à 32 départements de gauche qui
disent on nappliquera pas la voilà donc
là il y a enfin je veux dire c'est quand
même un sujet comme vous le savez le
social ce sont dans les départements ou
donc toutes les allocations qu'on
appelle non contributiv enfin on va pas
hein euh qui aujourd'hui sont euh euh
soumise donc dans un certain nombre de
cas un délai de carence plus important
qu'hier euh relève en terme de de
versement de guichet et cetera des
départements et là il y a il y a quelque
chose que moi je vais observer de très
près en tout cas qui est de voir comment
vont faire les départements c'est-à-dire
un président de département euh a déjà
eu l'idée et je pense qu'il est pas le
seul mais c'est le seul euh que j'ai
entendu le dire euh va décider que pour
ne pas se mettre hors la loi euh la pas
euh ne s'appellera plus la pas mais elle
s'appellera euh la loocation de secours
pour les personnes âgées moyen en quoi
il est pas du tout il se met pas du tout
hors la loi et ça c'est une forme entre
Guill c'est le président du du lot qui
qui a dit qui a dit ça et qui d'ailleurs
euh euh je crois que c'est ser sauvage
du sain de de mémoire son son n de
famille qui qui était euh un un soutien
de d'en marche qu
aniste voilà on voit bien qu'il s un
petit peu tout à fait c'est c'est
vraiment intéressant et et autant moi je
suis pour l'instant interrogative sur
est-ce que ce sont des frondeurs à la
frondeur sous Hollande ou où est-ce que
ce sont des frondeurs d'un soir je ne
sais pas encore mais je pense que la
fronde peut venir des collectivités
territorial et que ça peut être un vrai
sujet pour
l'exécutif alors-y vite là-dessus euh
c'est intéressant en terme de dynamique
de constater ce que vous venez
d'indiquer il faut rappeler un point
technique certes mais un point important
c'est que s'agissant du RSA qui est dans
la compétence des départements il y a
déjà de longues dates une condition de
durée de résidence de 5 ans pour les
étrangers non communautaires et ça ça
existe déjà aujourd'hui et ça n'a
éveillé aucune difficulté du côté des
départements en
questioné préférence nationale à ma
connaissance le problème de cette loi
c'est qu'elle ne règle elle ne contrôle
pas les flux migratoires on peut dire il
faut contrôler les flux migratoires
c'est ça serait sage de le faire elle ne
contrôle pas les flux migratoires elle
n'améliore pas non plus l'intégration
parce qu'on amaméliore pas l'intégration
des gens en compliquant leur accès au
logement en compliquant le leur accès à
la nationalité quand ils ont 18 ans et
qu'ils sont nés de parents étrangers
mais né en France en compliquant leur
accès à différentes allocations on on on
naméliore pas l'intégration cette loi
elle ne fait que valider tous les
épouvantails qu'ont agité la droite et
l'extrême droite depuis 20 ans les
étudiants étrangers qui viennent sont
des faux étudiants les malades étrangers
qui viennent viennent profiter de nos
système d'assurance maladie via laame
les ils viennent toucher nos alog tout
cette petite musique qu'on entend c'est
ça qui est validé dans ce texte mais
est-ce que ça va décourager les gens de
venir non est-ce que vous pensez que ça
va faire réfléchir les demandeurs
d'asile à Kandahar ou au sudsoudan bien
sûr que non les demandeurs d'asile
seront toujours là et puis les gens
voudront toujours venir en France ça ne
contrôle pas les je tour la main parce
que y y a vous l'avez évoqué avec cette
info les 32 départements de de gauche
qui annoncent qu'ils appliqueront pas
pas la la loi tel que ça pose la
question de sont effectivement qu'est-ce
qui va en rester et ça nous amène au
rôle du Conseil constitutionnel très
important je propose à Samia dechir de
nous rejoindre puisque le président de
la République l'a annoncé plusieurs
partis de de gauche plusieurs
associations de défense étrangèes ont
annoncé saisir le le Conseil
constitutionnel on va essayer de
détailler avec vous Samia les les
mesures qui effectivement pourrait
prêter à contestation dans le 10 conseil
constitionnel oui alors on ne sait pas
exactement encore combien il y en a il y
en aurait une trentaine d'après sache
aoulier qui est député de l'aelle gauche
de la majorité qui a voté contre le Tax
d'ailleurs alors nous on a pas compté
autant en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire
c'est qu'il y a plusieurs grandes
familles de mesures problématiques
d'abord il y a les ruptures d'égalité
sur les aides au logement par exemple
pour y avoir droit le projet de loi
immigration prévoit que les étrangers
devront résider en France depuis 3 mois
s'ils travaillent depuis 5 ans s'ils
n'ont pas d'emploi et ça ça peut être
considéré par le Conseil constitutionnel
comme une une rupture du principe
d'égalité entre les Français et les
immigrés et puis c'est le cas aussi pour
les quotas puisque je rappelle que le
texte voté hier prévoit de limiter le
nombre d'entrées sur le territoire
français via des quotas pluriannuels
d'immigration ce qui peut là encore
rompre le principe d'égalité mais cette
fois entre les candidats à l'immigration
regardez les explications du
constitutionnaliste Benjamin
Morel si jamais vous arrivez que vous
êtes le 100e sur le territoire à bien
remplir les critères et que le 51e lui
ne pourra pas obtenir de statut parce
que il est le sa1è parce qu'il y a un
quotat bien à ce moment-là vous
comprenez bien que à des situations qui
vont être les mêmes on va pas répondre
de la même façon alors autre point qui
qui concerne le le durcissement du
regroupement familial qui pourrait
évidemment on est au conditionnel dans
cette chronique lui aussi être toqué par
le Conseil constitutionnel oui parce que
le projet de loi immigration prévoit
pour le demandeur une durée de séjour en
France de 24 mois contre 18 aujourd'hui
des conditions de ressources stable
régulière et suffisante et pour le
demandeur pour le conjoint du demandeur
être âgé de 21 ans minimum et avoir une
connaissance de la langue française et
toutes ces conditions dans leur ensemble
elles peuvent être difficiles à réunir
ce qui est potentiellement une entorse à
un principe fondamental qui est inscrit
dans notre Constitution qui est protégé
par la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme c'est la protection de la vie
familiale et ça la première ministre
elle l'a reconnu elle-même ce matin au
micro de France Inter
regardez bah par exemple voyez il il est
prévu que vous ne pouvez pas si vous
épousez demain matin un canadien ou un
japonais il ne peut pas rejoindre le la
France s'il ne parle pas bien français
je pense que
çaf interroger on va interroger le
Conseil constitutionnel on a fait pas de
nos doutes au républicains avec lesquels
on a discuter donc le président de la
République va saisir le Conseil
constitutionnel Conseil constitutionnel
dira ce qu'il en est et puis Samia il y
a aussi ce que l'on appelle les
cavaliers législatifs oui des cavaliers
législatifs ce sont des mesures qui ont
été introduites dans un texte alors
qu'elles n'ont pas de lien avec l'objet
initial de ce texte et ça le Conseil
constitutionnel peut le censurer c'est
potentiellement le cas par exemple pour
la création d'un délit de séjour
irrégulier qui figure dans ce projet de
loi et puis aussi pour la modification
du droit du sol puisque je rappelle
qu'un enfant né en France de parents
étrangers n'obtiendra plus
automatiquement n'obtiendrait plus au
conditionnel automatiquement la
nationalité française il faudra qu'il en
manifeste la volonté entre ses 16 et ses
18 ans et ça c'est une mesure on
pourrait dire qui touche davantage au
code de la nationalité plutôt qu'à
l'immigration et donc c'est
potentiellement un cavalier législatif
alors sur toutes ces mesures Emmanuel
Macron va donc saisir le Conseil
constitutionnel la gauche aussi le
Conseil constitutionnel il peut décider
de censurer totalement ou partiellement
le projet de loi immigration totalement
la gauche en rêve mais mais c'est assez
improbable partiellement en revanche
c'est fort possible et tous les membres
de la majorité présidentielle qui ne
sont pas à l'aise avec les mesures les
plus controversés du du texte espère
bien qu'elles seront retoqué par le
Conseil constitutionnel merci Samia
Franck Morel je je reviens vers vous
est-ce qu'elle peut-être détricoté par
les sages à cette loi ben on a vu
d'autres cas de figure où effectivement
dans un certain nombre de situations le
Conseil constitutionnel a pu censurer
plusieurs dispositions il y a juste une
nuance moi que que j'apporterai par à la
présentation qui a été faite j'ai pas la
même lecture de la mesure cota entre
guillemets qui qui en a été faite j'ai
pas le sentiment tel
que il s'agit d'un cota bloquant
individuellement c'est-à-dire d'un quota
qui va induire le fait que
individuellement un refus va être
objecté à une personne j'ai plus le
sentiment que c'est un outil de de
pilotage public global Macro hein
c'est-à-dire qui va essayer de de de
mettre en perspective un certain nombre
de chiffres et de pilotage de ces
chiffres voilà c'est juste justement les
différentes acceptions qui peuvent
exister dans le monde de cette logique
de quota est-ce que c'est de la
politique publique ou est-ce que c'est
un qua quand même Fran sur le principe
le fait c'est ce que vous disz tout à
l'heure d'entendre la première ministre
le ministre de l'Intérieur finalement
justifier le fait d'avoir lâché du lest
en disant toute façon il y aura le
Conseil constitutionnel enfin c'est
quand même particulier comme disons que
ce qui est particulier c'est que des
fois on le fait sans le dire
c'est-à-dire que on a vu dans un certain
nombre de situations des amendements qui
étai qui pouvaient être acceptés en se
disant S bon de toute façon ça sera pas
l'obstacle du du Conseil conste je pense
que le fait de le dire est aussi dans le
cadre des équilibres recherchés avec une
partie de la majorité un acte en soi de
communication évidemment oui autre
déclaration de Macron ce soir sur
justement vous l'évoquz la caution la
demander au aux étudiants étrangers ben
il dit tout simplement ce n'est pas une
bonne idée donc alors fallait pas le
faire bah bon je dis pas le contraire je
ne fais que citer les propos du
président de la répu
non mais oui c'est assz c'est assez
délirant
effectivement Catherine tricot là
l'expression qui VI c'est tout ça pour
ça c'estàd que on va peut-être se
retrouver avec une loi vidée en grande
partie de sa substance et on se et et
cette majorité ce sera pardon d'être un
peu triviale mais payer une crise
politique assez majeure quoi oui mais
c'est pas tout ça pour ça c'estàd qu'en
fait quand Marine Le Pen dit c'est une
c'est une victoire idéologique qubien
même ça serait détricoté ça veut dire
qu'il y a quand même eu la validation
politique idéologique d'un certain
nombre de ses propositions de ses idées
qui jusqu'alors faisaient vraimentf qui
été récusé par l'ARC républicain et qui
maintenant ont été intégrés c'estàdire
que combien même ça le Conseil
constitutionnel reviendrait dessus
j'espère qu'il reviendra dessus mais du
point de vue de de de la victoire
politique et idéologique elle est
acquise parce qu'ils ont validé ça parce
qu'ils l'ont proposé qu'ils l'ont voté
et qu'ils ont fait la pression alors il
y a les LR qui l'ont proposé et il y a
le gouvernement qui a fait pression
comme des fous sur leur majorité pour
aller voter concernant les les LR
peut-être un mot rapide Sophie Coignard
est-ce que c'est une victoire à court
terme pour l'instant on peut dire que
c'est une victoire des LR oui mais moi
je pense que c'est c'est leur quart
d'heure
d'enchantement dans le quinquen
exactement c'est un peu ce que je
pensais c'est-à-dire que ah ouis là ils
ont fait un coup d'éclat absolument
formidable
effectivement mais avec que quel
lendemain c'est-à-dire que leur leur
rôle et leur place sur les chiquers
politiques et parlementaires n'a pas
changé ou s'il a changé comme le disait
Matthieu croissando c'est un peu à leur
détriment c'est-à-dire que être les
passe-epats euh du rassemblement
national ne me semble pas une position
comment vous dire qui a beaucoup
d'avenir pour dire de manière assez
basique donc je pense que je pense que
ah ça devait ça devait être bon je me
mets à leur place ça devait être
vraiment agréable tout à coup d'exister
de faire euh de faire danser euh oui
d'être uni absolument vous avez raison
et de faire danser le gouvernement la
majorité quel bon moment mais je pense
qu'on peut le résumer à quel bon moment
euh cela étant il y a quel pour euh par
rapport à ce que vous disiez il y a il y
a quand même euh une chose qui a changé
il me semble-t-il euh on peut le
déplorer mais euh entre le moment où
Emmanuel Macron ministre euh de François
Hollande euh approuvé Angela Merkel et
aujourd'hui c'est les Français euh il y
a il y a une question d'opinion publique
qui ne peut pas être totalement ignoré
euh par par les gens qui nous gouvern
par les il soutenait quand même alors
peut-être plus les mesures égaliennes
mais il soutenait en même temps quand on
regardait les Sondag c'est pour ça que
que enfin c'est pour ça que il y a y a
une vraie différence me semble-t-il
entre le texte euh initial euh le projet
de loi d'armanin ou le texte qui est
sorti de la de la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale et le texte qui a
été voté et effectivement dans le
surréalisme on a vous prenez un martien
vous lui faites écouter ellisabeth borne
et il dit mais qu'est-ce qui est cette
personne d'opposition euh ah ouais
l'argumente pas mal donc enfin on voit
bien qu'il y a il y a une il y a il y a
un jeu politique à renverser qui pose un
problème je vous parlais des Français
qui pose un problème aussi vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique c'est-à-dire que fer
mumuse fire mumuse avec tout ça i
compris et de la part de la gauche à
quelques mois des élections européennes
moi je suis pas je suis pas totalement
enthousiasmé par cette idée celle qui
pouvait aussi un peu sembler dans
l'opposition c'était la la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale ce matin sur BFM
TV on écoute il bronpivet il y en a il y
en a moi la question des des prestations
sociales me gêne terriblement je l'ai
dit au président de la République hier
soir avant vousz à l'ÉÉ pour cette
réunion d'urgence j'étais à l'élyisé
et à la question qu'est-ce qui vous gêne
dans ce texte moi j'ai répondu que la
question des prestations sociales me
gênait que je n'approuvais pas le fait
de de priver une personne en situation
régulière qui par exemple peut avoir des
enfants sur le territoire français
d'allocation familiale ou d'allocation
logement et donc je trouvais que le
délai de carence
ne me convenait pas je l'ai dit
président de l'Assemblée nationale 4e
personnage de l'État quand même
Catherine tricot moi je je j'entendais
vos arguments fr Morel mais ressouder ça
va être compliqué moi c'est l'impression
quand même que j'ai ce soir oui c'est
c'est tout à fait évident qu'il y a une
crise qui s'est ouverte en effet pour la
raison qu'on a dit c'est qu'en fait il y
a un changement de pied enfin
véritablement il y a un changement de
pied de de d'un équilibre qui était pas
qui était un peu instable et qui s'est
renversé et qui maintenant en effet
c'est on tourne vers les LR qui tourne
vers l'extrême droite et à propos cette
question d'opinion publique j'entends
bien ce que vous dites sur l'évolution
de l'opinion publique le seul problème
c'est que un l'opinion publique ça se
travaille c'est qu'on n'est pas obligé
d'alimenter parce que quand on écoute
par exemple sur d'autres sujets Gabriel
Atal sur quoi il fait sa rentrée
scolaire il nous l'a fait sur la BAA et
puis après sur l'uniforme à l'école
c'estàd quand même là encore des
propositions ou des idées qui sont des
diagnostics et des propositions de
l'extrême droite je veux dire c'est
quand même un projet de
loi je suis pas du tout prête à vous ê
mais
CTA c'est possible madame c'est possible
madame mais au mois de janvier de
l'année dernière au mois de janvier de
l'année
dernière au mois de janvier l'année
dernière l'extrême droite avait proposé
Marine Le Pen avait proposé un projet de
loi sur l'uniforme à l'école donc non
mais ce que je vous dis c'est que ils
reprennent des thématiques qui sont
portées par l'extrême droite en
diagnostic et en proposition ce qui
fracture le ce qui ne répond pas à la
question des flux migratoires ce qui
nous divise alors qu'il y a des sujets
sur lequels il faudrait unir le pays
Emmanuel Macron avait dit mon mandat
sera écologique ou ne sera pas il n'en
est plus question vous entendez cette
musique ça veut dire que l'émission est
en train de se terminer bah oui mais il
y av encore mais on a dit déjà beaucoup
de choses passionnantes merci je vais
terminer tiens par une dernière citation
du président de la République ça c'est
bien du Macron à propos de la question
est-ce une victoire éthéologique du
rassemblement national il dit c'est une
manœuvre de garçon de bain c'est
grossier voilà ce ce voilà cette
sémantique sur rané qui qui intervient
et qui apparaît parfois dans les
discours d'éel Mac merci
merci c'est plutôt la plaisanterie de
garçon l'expression oui c'est ça merci
beaucoup plaisanterie à tous d'avoir
participer à cette émission je vrais
remercier rapidement toutes les équipes
de public Sena en cette fin d'année
parce que c'est notre dernier direct de
la saison on se retrouve en en janvier
les équipe de la rédaction les équipes
techniques évidemment c'est toujours
aussi agréable de travailler avec avec
vous merci encore je vous donne
rendez-vous au mois de janvier belle
soirée on sera là mais avec les
meilleurs moments de l'émission voilà
18h 22h on n pas totalement parti mais
Siou en janvier
merci